I think that our understanding of how
human genomics is going to play a role
in helping us understand which patients
are most likely to respond to a new
therapy so all patients are not created
equal they may have a particular medical
problem that has brought them to our
attention at this moment but we have to
understand that in the context of other
genetic issues or environmental issues
they may be facing or their age or other
thing so being able to put that together
and using the information from the human
genome and their understanding of how
genetic networks play together to add up
to the health care status of a person i
think is going to be incredibly
enlightening it's going to allow us to
develop drugs more quickly because we'll
know which patients are more likely to
respond to a therapy than others will
get the right patients in a clinical
trial and be able to test it more
effectively for infectious diseases I
think learning about the host is also a
potential breakthrough opportunity for
us because we not only need to think
about how did the bugs work but how do
we as patients or host for those
pathogens respond to the presence of a
pathogen some people never get sick you
know these people walking around they
need to seem to never get a cold other
people get everyone that comes by what
is the difference in our makeup that
makes some of us more susceptible to
infections that others what may what is
it that contributes to get appropriately
responding so we also know that some
patients in the hospital when they get a
bacterial infection respond with a very
strong immune response that actually is
more of a problem than the bacteria
itself it can lead to a syndrome called
sepsis where the inflammatory system
actually sort of goes haywire in its
desire to deal with the pathogen you
know dampening that down in
understanding the network controlling
that is another opportunity that I think
will come to us from from human genomics
so I see that as an area that is just
going to open up a whole host of
solutions to us
it occurs to me that cancer obviously is
an area that certainly benefit from this
we know that not all cancers are the
same not all patients develop of the
same manifestations of cancer and that
there are familial linkages you know
that are related to the propensity to
develop certain types of cancers versus
others and the interplay between our
genes in the environment there does
translate into you know a situation that
affects cancer I think there's a lot of
promise their diabetes again is another
genetic when both type 1 and type 2 well
I think there is the potential to learn
a lot and to me I think the the whole
central nervous system and an area focus
for our neurosciences group what
contributes to some manifestations of
various psychoses propensity to get
Alzheimer's disease autism things like
that I think all of those will then if
all those areas will benefit
substantially from from breakthroughs in
human genome